in the expanse season 5
earth is ravaged with asteroids sent by
marco inaros
who leads a militant belter rebellion
against earth and mars
naomi is imprisoned by marco and their
son
philip she jumps through space to escape
and
alex dies saving her amos and clarissa
fight to survive on an apocalyptic earth
holden struggles to contain the
proto-molecule fred johnson is killed
and in the finale a rogue martian
faction leaves the solar system for a
new world called
laconia and one of their ships is
destroyed by mysterious
alien entities so what's going on here
this video has no spoilers from the
books just stuff from the tv show
up to season five so for generations the
people of mars have worked to terraform
the planet into a habitable world
with breathable air and life but in
season three
the alien ring gates opened up hundreds
of already habitable worlds
planets like illus that have life and
rich resources
so mars is now obsolete people start
leaving but mars still has a heap of
advanced military gear lying around and
with its government in disarray
stuff goes missing bobby and alex
discover a conspiracy in the military to
give
advanced martian warships to marco
anaros and his free navy
in return marco gives them the
protomolecule sample that he steals from
fred
in the finale we learned that this
martian conspiracy is led by someone
called
admiral duarte and juarte's martians
take a whole fleet of ships and eat out
of the solar system through the ring
gate
because they made a deal that marco can
have the soul system
while duarte's faction rule a system
called laconia
this has actually been hinted at all
season if you zoom in on the opening
credits it shows a martian ship flying
to laconia so on laconia juarte has the
scientist
cortazar studying mysterious alien
structures
and experimenting with the
proto-molecule remember
that billions of years ago there was an
alien civilization
called the builders the builders created
the proto-molecule as a tool to build
these ring gates
but the proto-molecule also has the
potential to be a weapon
or to transform the human species
in season two cortisol said that the
proto-molecule
learns and changes that it devours
old constructs and recreates them
it seems that juarte and his martians
want to
recreate the dream of mars a conspirator
said that the dream of
mars isn't dead it's about to be writ
large sorvitar says that mars is not
just one
planet it's a vision of humanity that
can encompass a thousand stars
he says that laconia will be pure and
unified
strict and militant the name laconia
refers to sparta
in ancient greece which is renowned as a
military society
so jawate has started a whole new
faction of martian military on the
distant world of laconia
empowered by alien technology but
they're playing with fire
one of gewate's ships enters the laconia
ring
and is suddenly destroyed by mysterious
alien
entities these are the creatures that
killed the builders billions of years
ago using weapons like that artifact on
illus
and now these entities are a threat to
humans too
so season 5 shatters the balance of
power in the expanse with laconia
splitting off from mars
earth devastated marco's free navy
rising in the belt and strange aliens
haunting the ring gates
but at the same time as all this sci-fi
and politics this season is also
deeply personal with amos naomi and alex
each going on journeys to face
their pasts amos grew up
in baltimore as a child his name was
timothy
and he was sexually exploited as a child
prostitute
then worked as muscle in organized crime
a woman named lydia was
like a mother to timothy and she taught
him that even if
you're not a good person you can still
live
like a good person you can pretend to be
righteous
because amos doesn't feel empathy for
others
hurting people makes him feel good he
can't tell right from wrong
he's a damaged person but by following a
guiding light like lydia or naomi or
holden
amos can learn to do the right thing and
live
a good life lydia has died
so amos pays his respects to her husband
charles
and then visits his old friend eric back
in the day
timothy's boss was amos burton and
burton ordered timothy to kill eric
timothy killed burton instead and took
burton's identity to escape earth and
start a new life
as amos now eric is a crime boss himself
and amos gets him to provide housing for
charles
and before leaving earth forever amos
visits clarissa
in season 3 clarissa murdered a bunch of
people trying to get revenge on holden
for imprisoning her father
but afterwards amos made friends with
clarissa so
he visits her in an underground prison
called the pit
clarissa is in a deep dark place
emotionally and literally so amos helps
and supports clarissa
in the same way that naomi and lydia
helped him
which goes to show how much amos has
grown
while they're in the pitch one of
marco's asteroids hits america
and they have to work together to climb
out of the darkness into the light
like a metaphor for escaping their
emotional pain
they also kick a cybernetically enhanced
super thug in the balls which is a
metaphor for kicking their emotional
pain in the boss
amos still isn't good at this talking
about your feelings stuff so he's almost
glad when the world starts ending and
they've gotta fight to survive
violence he understands amos says that
in times of conflict
human groups fracture into small hostile
tribes
but clarissa has a more optimistic
inclusive perspective and she convinces
amos to help some refugees escape earth
with the help of eric they find a ship
and fight some goons and fly
to safety on the moon there eric asks
amos to come with him to start a crime
gang like the old days
but amos rejects his dark past and
chooses a more optimistic future
he brings clarissa to join the rosie
crew
arguing that even murderous enemies can
become
trusted friends so amos suffered
terrible trauma and violence and he can
never fully escape
that past but he can learn to be better
and help others to be better too amos
survives the churn by growing his tribe
naomi also faces her past years ago
she was involved with belter radicals
marco sin
and coral naomi and marco had a baby
called philip
marco was passionate and charismatic but
was also an emotionally manipulative
narcissistic
terrorist he used some computer code
that naomi wrote to blow up a ship
called the gemara
killing 500 people naomi was
horrified and tried to leave so marco
took
baby phillip away from her naomi became
desperate
and depressed and almost committed
suicide at an airlock
she did manage to start a new life but
always felt guilty
about the child she left behind in
season five
she and philip finally reunite naomi
hopes to save her son
from being used by marco like she was
but
phillip stays loyal to his controlling
father
and naomi is imprisoned on marco's ship
series creator ty frank says marco is
like
a bad guy version of holden they're both
brave passionate leaders who fight for
what they believe in
but where holden is selfless and
compassionate and honest
marco is a selfish cruel liar and
murderer who commits the worst mass
killing
in history sin is more friendly with
naomi
he was always a brotherly protective
figure to her
kind of like amos naomi's actress
dominic tipper says that that similarity
might be what drew naomi to amos in the
first place
naomi tries desperately to convince
philip to leave
marco but ultimately he rejects her and
naomi is again unable to save her son
so naomi escapes by jumping through the
vacuum of space unprotected to another
ship
which apparently is scientifically
possible if you're quick
especially since naomi injects herself
with oxygenated blood
she suffers swelling and radiation burns
and
almost dies but that's just the
beginning of her torment
because naomi is stuck inside a trap
designed to lure and
kill her friends it's a disabled ship
with a fake distress call
rigged to explode using naomi's own code
from the gemara
it's like naomi's past has been
weaponized to destroy her
but naomi uses her skills and her grit
to survive
this hellish trap she leaps into space
again
to warn her friends and is rescued by
alex
and bobby alex goes back to mars to
reconnect with his ex-wife
and son who he had left behind to go be
a pilot
but his ex rejects him and alex has to
accept that
some mistakes can't be fixed so he helps
bobby
investigate black market martian
military gear he talks to salvatere and
babbage who are both secretly working
for duate
and they chase after the conspirators
and bobby does heroic bobby things
alex and bobby are both loyal martians
and they're furious that the government
that they fought for has betrayed them
they grieve that the dream of mars is
dying
when naomi is in danger they race in to
save her
flying at a high g burn is always
dangerous
they use the juice to reduce the risk of
stroke but
it's always a roll of the dice and this
time it goes against them
and alex dies alex's last words
are that was one hell of a ride all he
ever wanted to do
was to fly and to fight to do good with
his crew
so dying to save naomi after a crazy
ride in the razorback
is a fitting death for this martian
space cowboy
so while amos naomi and alex go off on
their own journeys
holden is left alone he's lonely without
his crew but
soon monika and fred keep him busy cause
monica gets kidnapped and they save her
but then marco's men
attack and kill fred fred
was the voice for peace and cooperation
between the belt and inner planets
and he was almost like a father figure
to holden
he had just told holden to live life
while he can
and now he's dead when marco's men
steal fred's protomolecule sample holden
bull and monica
chase after it when they find out naomi
is in danger holden wants to charge in
and save her
but he realizes that this time he can't
help her
and the proto-molecule is more important
this is the opposite of what happened in
season two when holden was obsessed with
hunting down the proto-molecule
but then learned to let it go because in
that case
saving naomi was more important once
upon a time
holden was a heroic white knight who
always knew what was right and wanted to
save
everyone all the time now he's much more
mature and wise able to compromise
and make difficult choices about what's
right
last season drama left the opa because
she was done with having to sacrifice
lives for the sake of politics so now
she sets her own path as a polyamorous
space pirate
captain she has a family of five other
belters on a couple of ships
and extorts people for resources in her
part of space
but like every other character this
season the past
comes back to haunt her she finds the
ship of
ashford who was killed by marco last
season
previously drummer and ashford had
captured marco
and would have killed him but drama
spared marco
leading to ashford's death so drama
suffers grief and guilt over the death
of her friend
drummer had always been so tough and
professional but now we see
her vulnerable intimate side and her
relationships with her partners
when marco rises to power with the free
navy
drummer has no choice but to join the
man who killed
two of her friends her longtime ally
fred
as well as ashford drummer's partner
oksana says for the safety of their
family they must stay loyal to marco
but then drummer learns that naomi is in
danger from marco
naomi and drummer survived the behemoth
together
they danced and handbold together naomi
built drummer's robot legs when she was
paralyzed
so drummer won't let marco kill another
of her friends
she rebels against marco attacks his
ships helps save naomi
and reclaims her independence but
there's a terrible cost
marco kills one of drummer's partners
and oksana blames drummer
so her family breaks apart
last season avasarala was the most
powerful person on earth
but after losing her election she's
relegated to the moon and the government
doesn't listen to her anymore
her daughter says she should just go
home and patch things up with her
estranged husband arjun
but other sarala's whole identity and
purpose is to use politics to protect
earth
and she finds evidence of marco's plan
to throw stealth rocks at earth
by the time anyone listens it's too late
earth is devastated and arjun is one of
the dead
the new acting secretary general
retaliates against marco with an attack
that kills
thousands of belter civilians in the
past avasarala
probably would have supported this she
agreed to the destruction of daimos in
season 2
and attacked a civilian ship last season
but now
she doesn't want to repeat the mistakes
of the past
killing civilians will only create more
terrorists and avasarala feels
responsible to protect not just earthers
but
all people so she resigns in protest of
the attack
and it works others resign with her the
power
shifts and avasarala becomes
secretary-general again
the once and future queen in the end
she calls for unity among earth mars and
the belt
as they face the new threats of the free
navy
and laconia so in season five
the sins of the past come back to punish
the protagonists
marco's free navy arose from a century
of oppression of the belters by earth
and mars
naomi is almost destroyed by marco using
her own computer code
juarte and laconia's protomolecule
sample is the one that naomi refused to
destroy back in season two
naomi fails to save philip holden
fails to contain the proto-molecule alex
fails to repair his past
drummer fails to protect her family of
assarallah fails to protect
earth this season is the empire strikes
back of the expanse in that
the good guys lose if there's any hope
in this story maybe it's in amos and
clarissa
who emerge from trauma and apocalypse
with
new optimism and unity
thanks for watching we made four videos
for the expanse season 5 with the
support of our sponsor
amazon prime video uk so please check
out their channel at the link below
thanks to patrons brendan davis willie
hardy mike batko
ross maverick ben dieter stanislav ian
fei big huang
newen and demps2002 cheers